but I've vlog just didn't work out
anyway one of the more interesting jam
sessions I've had in a while is with the
uber talented Big KRIT if you haven't
listened to his new double album go
check it if you guys are doing super
well on this holiday weekend and getting
geared up for that December crunch check
it watch it
thank you so much for being subscribed
actually a lot of you aren't subscribe
now if you're not
[Music]
how are you little pleasures the same
you how are you my man
yeah a real pleasure hey how are you
such a pleasure are you doing come in
it's a thicker come from man carry this
real pleasure how are you good
how you doing my man what's up my man
we got WWF belts up here martial
education how are you how are things
thank you my man this is the room how
you doing good man it's a real pleasure
to meet you up and looking forward to it
hey man how's life everybody's grown and
changed and went through star finishes
I'm pitching backup English like that
man
plans your back kind of thing took
appealing right arm and fresh was
refreshing to be out of the studio it
was hard for me to let go the fact I
didn't have anything to do at the moment
because I felt awkward right different
call him I present
where do you live good for you how long
you New York got a lot of promotion and
all that kind of stuff I know you always
yep my man sleep is important I'm not
worried about how many hours people
sleep I'm worried about what they're
doing when they're awake I'm trying to
get six seven eight hours like the body
is not joking around like I got a little
bit of a dump is just complaining I'm
going to Australia next week for two
days and I'm only sleeping two hours I
don't know what my assistant was
thinking but but in general but in
general in general like I I get scared
when people think the whole hustle
mantra that I like to push is about not
sleeping yeah because like I'm trying to
talk more about it that's why I have
this like good line like I'm not worried
about what you do and you know sleep I'm
worried about what you do when you are
awake just so people get it but yeah it
to me it's when you're awake it's those
18 hours that really really matter you
know because people people are just
wasting their at-bat you know 100% and
then you prefer to sit and dwell and
complain and people just come up with a
million reasons why not to do right do
you know Prince workers Jenner for
studio time do you know that dude
that to me gets me fired to [ __ ] up
because I don't know I assume you get
plenty this too and diem and all this
but like obviously since I just get so
many kids who wanna be you and they're
like and a lot of them don't have much
and I'm like orca chick-fil-a save your
money go to studio I mean like I don't
know like you know like what do you want
me to tell you well that's that's that
next you know that's that's and then
what's even crazier actually is the [ __ ]
you can now do that doesn't even need
studio time in just six right some of
you and I grew up with right yeah I mean
the technology is you know what this is
just it's just sup it's just suffocating
out excuses you know right right so
what's going on with your guys team like
like how do you know obviously I know
you guys have enough context for us I've
seen different outreaches we've talked
I've watched we've talked like listen
like is there anything that over since
we got time together is there anything
that stands out that I can answer I can
help with us anything we could do like
and please go ahead and as the person
that probably has the most context on
both sides feel free you got some new
cool shoes huh I know exactly what about
the sag and then they bounce the album
and it was so low in the car we walked
him we push the master fader down so we
could do that's amazing she told
I believe about music being loud is she
knocking like it's kind of inch louder
because like on Def Jam doing his thing
now he's off Def Jam independent doing
this thing independently and he's at
like this cool position I feel thinking
was in the year 2017 he has all the pans
gives all the attention you know their
value of attention in a two second like
some people just so natural II
charismatic and like people and that's
the biggest [ __ ] advantage if you have
that from your I know you well enough to
know from what angle because I know so
your next follow-up is yes a music wow
from an OG I understand also like cuz
I'm funny like as a person that listens
to music and this is the reason I love
hip-hop it's less about production and
music and beats it is I mean it's so
much more about the words like like
because it's I just resonate with it cuz
I'm competitive I came up with not much
like it like to me I'm not my media
empire looks a lot more like slinging
you know disks from the back of a truck
and that's why I it's you know that's
why I resonate with it so every time
like the music parts always funny to me
because I never want to front to be like
oh yeah yeah I don't really know okay
like like like I love Metro boomin like
him yeah but to understand his craft
versus somebody who writes I there's a
big disconnect for me okay I don't
understand Muse like to I like what you
said you know that's just not what I do
like telling you how to make sure every
single eSports kid on earth [ __ ] with
you that I own
and making sure that every Latino
fourteen-year-old guy [ __ ] with you so
that in ten years when they're the
majority of the US market that I can
tell you how to hack Singapore to like
when you go over there and you're like
the number one that I understand but
understanding like oh the but when
people like that then when people like
that base I'm like yeah that base like I
don't understand that I matter I
understand it but I understand it
doesn't go through me like that how
about white why do you think that did
you grow up in a musical family so is
the answer obviously gospel all in blues
and my dad playing Scarface you know and
I'm getting it from him and my mom is
playing Whitney Houston so I got all
those things and then I saw a house
music on my own and then you talking
about old school records and people
highlight and discover and Curtis
Mayfield Bobby Womack really hood and
that's how I got the blues and what
about you and what about so that's
classic and so what about new like when
you were how old are you look good is
that that's what helps you I get it I D
Wade the other day I was watching I was
watching the X Games like oh do you wake
the haircut looks good but when 31 so
how about when you were growing up who
like who would a new guys that like
Scarface's I'm saying more like but he
was already even a generation to old are
like yeah the whole LA read Atlanta
thing was just so game-changing it was
like Motown all over again of course but
the duty of where I'm growing up in a
small town except for Mississippi were
in the city is that radio played your
top 10 record from everywhere but when I
was from so I got a good understanding
of East Coast and West Coast and what
that feels like
in tempos and how that music
sounded so when it came time to do
features and work with people who know
the signs of hmm right so that was a
benefit of people not playing music
so being independent the release here
direct-to-consumer and then what like
digital dude right yeah I spent so long
because I was always raises you don't do
it you so humility you write my song and
so there's new world yeah and I run into
a thing where India today was like bread
and it's not use naturally let me tell
you how as somebody who goes to the
complete other way yeah and peacocks you
know it's probably the way you feel
about your music man I feel so good
about what I'm saying that I'm willing
to take the heat okay you know many
people don't put out music because I
don't want to take the heat most of them
so you need to you need to not talk when
he wants you to because it's smart
strategy you need to find a way to when
you feel something to talk because if
you're right if you can convert it in
the way you think about music the reason
I'm putting out so much [ __ ] is I got
something to say yeah yes so listen he's
maybe maybe maybe so maybe he's like so
maybe take so maybe take the strategy
that I took listen if you did a [ __ ]
Instagram story right now and I'm said
I'm taking an intern to be my
videographer I'm not gonna pay you [ __ ]
you get to follow me around and make
video follow me and make videos and put
it out yeah [ __ ] ten thousand people
raising their hand
I would you know many people would rip
their arm off that love you more than
life to do that and you'll if you learn
and this and that you should do that I
can see that you're comfortable in this
kind of environment I thought this was
gonna be the hardest thing I ever did
cuz I was like two years ago and I
decided to film everything I did I'm
like see that's some douchey ass [ __ ]
right like I was like like how am I
gonna explain that
you know but but I just knew it was
right and and and that's what listen
it's all about putting players in a
position to succeed okay right and music
and sports and business like when
somebody wants to become a producer
because they just want to be a producer
but they're really a writer it gets
[ __ ] up you got to do your thing if
it's not your thing to self start and
tweet and put up an Instagram then build
around you
I'm too busy I'm running a big ass
company so I need them following me
around and filming so I surrounded
myself with people just like you've got
people around you that can do other
things you need somebody collecting
content you're doing a lot of
interesting [ __ ] eat I mean do you know
how [ __ ] amazing it would be right
now to put out a forty seven minute
documentary on Facebook of those two
years short-haired crib but you know
like all this magic lost in time yeah
like in the world that I live in my dome
imagine all those videos we could be
watching up when POC and Biggie war
friends like you don't fun this is my
man you and I are gonna sit down and
break and eat some food in 13 years and
pull up our phone or whatever
and watch this that's amazing so I think
so I call it documenting versus creating
you're an artist so I imagine through
your head when you're putting out a
tweet you're probably putting that extra
layer over over thinking it from an
artistic level I respect that and I
don't want you to help it but I want to
create a framework that allows you to
like put up and by the way let me go on
a real crazy left turn on you you're
just gonna like having this when you're
an old man because your kids are gonna
be able to watch it super real and not
only want to get into the way I think
about [ __ ] which AI and virtual reality
like I like in the world that I live in
my kids my great great grandkids long
after I'm gone are gonna sell this
meeting sell it as virtual reality and
then
actually sitting right there because
they think you're cool because they
think I'm cool cuz I'm their great
grandpappy and they're gonna sell it
yeah it's crazy but I promise you the
guy that drew Batman never thought in 70
years there's gonna be billion dollar
movies made of like you don't you can't
project that far out but I can a little
bit a little bit a little bit right so
documenting versus creating credit like
like don't anything that creates
friction for you he already knows you're
not gonna do it so you're just gonna be
so hack I think it's this I think you
guys do some sort of like outreach like
one post and then people like look at it
and be like interview three kids feel
good about them make sure it's not just
star [ __ ] and they're like you know
that's what we do like we get thousands
of entries every time we got a new
person we vet you know and it'll work
for you man
you think about how much fun it's gonna
be for them imagine you're a crit van
and like now you're on tour now you just
felt like you live in the dream everyday
and there's interesting ones this is an
unusual one then there's on stage then
there's another unusual one then there's
the moment where you're just walking
down the street and somebody tells you
this song did this for them captured and
you decide to put that on Instagram
because you thought something and then
you start getting used to it and then
different shits and then you start
creating then you start off the
interaction you start looking at the
camera making a point for it you know
you start getting feedback you're and
your social media grows because of this
and then people are leaving comments and
you're getting that feedback and it's
just you know right it's counterpunching
you start reacting did people think you
waited too long no what do you think
like what like two years is like I'm you
know in a world where people put out
mixed like
I gotta tell you the fans were
consistently asking yeah he got the
point where pictures don't pose no faces
we don't you know we knew that the
project was coming so we do think was
coming we didn't post on purpose but
they it was a consistent and so where
you let where you so much so fast
that's always the to be very frank
that's the [ __ ] that always scares me
because you get crippled by that Prop
mean you know I'm older that Dre project
like that was like you know never
happened for doubt you know it never
happened you know like and this is
pre-internet back in the kind of a lower
early you know that was like once they
come in and to that point man some of
the stuff some of the stuff that was in
your in your head and two years ago like
I was under a good over my you needed
you needed to do that and do you think
that's always how you're gonna need it
or do you think now that you did it this
way it gives you like okay did it that
way once you know like no I think I
think because the two years was figuring
out how to work with musicians how to
get out of my comfort zone how did not
record in my house double-time I can go
to other studios to get creative
criticism and not take it so personally
that I needed that so now going into the
next one is gonna be like you weren't
wrong and that's the first thing I
realized hand well at a time when people
telling me people donated concert she
really just want something radio and I'm
like brother
I got this record is about life and I
wasn't wrong like no people are hurting
is a human things and we superheroes
when go to work when when we buy silly
trying to figure it out and to put on it
in a high woman to make music like that
is very necessary and there's a space
for me come pretty man yeah and so as
long as you understand your process man
I give you know I'm happy
music and it's no spaces I don't mean
the painter was missing
crazy-cool yeah I was just telling crit
earlier like I was listening to this
song that song it really touched me and
that's why to answer your question to an
artist like him doesn't get hurt too
hard waiting a long time because the
music is so real it's not like catchy or
vibey or like of the moment like his
music is touching your mom instead of me
rapping just to be grabbing some sarnies
well yeah thank you my man Cassie it's
basically me tell you about my life in
transparency you know and which is
easier for me to do that sometimes and
again like with the cameras like music
is my therapy and so when I'm dropping
these songs I is literally forgetting
everything the morning that I wrote it I
was going through something and are you
thinking about the thing that I so I'm a
big thing in me and advertising well why
we popped was I think the markets always
right and I mean 100 percent I've never
sat in the moment of my career on
anything I've done from my dad's liquor
business to me being a public persona if
it didn't work they were right I was
wrong
and as I've spent a lot more time with
artists and I don't mean just hip-hop
artists I mean the 300 people my
creative Department mighty artists the
ego stops them from the humility that
becomes their strength so one thing I've
been really interested in is the notion
of like sitting and listening to albums
right and like and and then
understanding like they want one of the
songs to be the single mm because it's
the one that wrote that meant the most I
do it to there's some [ __ ] I talk about
patients
I want 20 I want more than life for all
these 30 year old and others to have
patience cuz they can win you know they
can win if they're not short cutting you
know true confidence like why do you
need things
oh because you're insecure and you want
to get girls with it or you want to show
somebody that you made it that
insecurity stops you from really getting
there
right so there's things I'm passionate
about so when I make content around that
I'm like I hope this goes and when it
doesn't I'm fine with it
I just collect it so you're talking
about something with a boogie that I
thought was interesting and and
something I've been thinking a lot about
as we continue to have these meetings
I'm trying to help bring value is the
notion of the single so this comes out
I'm dying to know the meetings of this
crew and definitely dying to know what's
going through your head for weeks of
like what's gonna be the single and I
don't know if that's how you think about
it but damn 90% 95% maybe a hundred
percent and definitely if you got a
label like I know you don't definitely
if you do they're picking what's the
single right but even as an artist like
I still think everybody's got a favorite
child
so let's just start with that for a
minute I'm fascinated by that in the
environment we now live in that made a
lot of sense to me when radio play yeah
but that's you know how some [ __ ] just
gets carried over cuz that's the way it
was I'm just this is there's not a final
thought this is my brainstorm mmm I
think well I know what the lead single
is the ones that they told us are the
lead singles there's a way to harness
the reality of the market and you have
that pure humility that does not come
natural to anybody in the field of art
go ahead please that's what he was more
fashion metal of course by the way of
course there's only one of two things
there's the business people saying this
one because it's gonna sell [ __ ] and
then there's the artist or the artistic
people saying this is the one that means
most I get that I'm about the third one
which is the [ __ ] market right so now
we put those two out as a launching pad
but we put the project out on top of
this so now the market came out like 19
was a single that's really coming back
from the market I get it me we
definitely brought of course I knew it
myself it was in by the way we all know
that like that's happened for years for
people's albums yeah you've been what
you've been wanting to scratch that itch
yeah
that hook is gonna work on radio I got
it I get I get it it's an interesting
thing but you can't get on the radio yes
I am with people do that man I hate that
song but they fired instead of listening
to it and knowing it because it's on the
radio is still running this silently so
there's something else I've been
thinking about I want to throw you since
the vibes I'm feeling this is something
I've been see haven't heard this one yet
for me I got it I got one I got one that
I've been reading no cuz deep down I
wish I was a rapper and then she would
be so much more fun I would I would be
thought that I just wish I knew how to
flow I believe you believe I actually
really think I'm gonna try to train
myself into figuring it out because I've
got it but I don't have it
like you know what I mean like got it
it's why I do what I do and it works and
you see it it's working in culture it's
just not done through anyway
this I'm dying to see your perspective -
I have a concept that I haven't seen ok
song comes out album comes out project
comes out something pops in movies they
come out with number two quick you put
out right guardians of the galaxy
you're like what the [ __ ] Eman it blows
up in the theater they're [ __ ] in
production on number two from the Beth
so so for me again back to lyrics you
write a song it's about what you're
going through with your girl with your
best friend but somebody's sick in your
family and it goes well it's been some
time in between you writing that and now
it happening to write the update and
piggyback off the momentum is something
I've never seen there's something there
song goes immense something you know a
lot of stuff goes that doesn't it but it
meant something the words yes sir the
remix is to is a some form of a
collaboration that's building off the
equity of the popularity what I'm
referring to especially if you write is
a different song but literally is like
the like the name is like the follow up
or what happened what is ready for this
I do believe that I think right I think
right here right now we're creating a
genre called what happened :
and the name of the song the follow up
like that's interesting artistically yes
but I'm going I'm going
yeah yeah exactly I am yes I'm saying
I'm saying this is out 1999 when you
write 2000 like or like something like
there's some there's is something that
so what people don't realize is
distributions been commoditized the
process that Michael Jackson had to go
through doesn't exist you put this
project out and like we get to your
point
something's popping we're getting
feedback back now back to your point
artistically if you can't get the
momentum to write the follow-up or the
update
mazelTov but if you can now you're
breaking new ground like I think for a
hip hop it could become an
there used to not be anything called the
remix I'm old my grew up like there was
no remix there isn't something called
the follow-up or the update but I think
it could happen the speed in which you
can do things that's that [ __ ]
excites because I'm in it for you have
to understand who I am as a listener I'm
in it for the story you're you know what
I'm not worried about you I'll tell you
why because I couldn't even spend a lot
up can I answer how you're gonna keep a
genuine you don't know any other options
that's why you ask the question so
honestly if I was part of this crew I'd
be like yo 99s poppin or this song's
poppin and that songs poppin you got
something you like like it first of all
when it's your crew or you you know your
life if nothing's happened since you
wrote that about the baby mama drama
or the grandpa or the city there's
nothing to talk about but if there is
right so one thing you'll love it was
the first thing I said to you and this
is where I'm connecting with you right
now I've never said anything I don't
believe in in my [ __ ] life so in a
weird way even though I'm such a
businessman I have that one attachment
with artists I've never said a damn
[ __ ] word I don't believe in so like
there's been opportunities like I could
be making a lot of money talking about
some [ __ ] like so I get you but if
there's something to say and take
advantage of culture that we now live in
because people have not seen this white
space that I'm seeing you do okay good
interesting right it's you know you know
why I love that and why I pitched it to
you is because I'm feeling your vibe
that's art because now you're inventing
some [ __ ] yeah now you're going over
here and be like yo you know like this
is a whole new territory of thing and as
for a writer that's a
credible because that flexibility to
like right back to what you said sadness
for two years because I don't feel like
I have to go back and say and it like I
did it right but as you know sometimes
when you're telling a story there's an
update and be like and so to me for a
lot of the stories I listen to every day
I'm like oh what happened you know it
with that girl that broke your heart or
what happened with you know okay it's
been a year since grandpa died and he
was your [ __ ] North Star like how you
doing like what about writing the fact
that you visited the cemetery like like
what cuz it's stories there's something
there
especially if something to me it's that
something pops and there's an actual
story get the [ __ ] studio and get
that out I can see a tsunami and this is
what they want me did the connection of
as far as like people obviously
well that's why it would work for you
you're not just talking about like going
to the club and having fun which is
great and when you're telling life
stories like didn't stop and this story
might have been finished but this story
might be just starting and if that song
went and you've got a couple more lines
to add to the equation you see where I'm
going
I say I'm looking for because I'm
looking well I'm looking deeply through
his glasses and I'm watching his eyes
this is interesting [ __ ] I'm not fooling
around here this is something different
okay go ahead drink one those are things
are like [ __ ] $14 drink drink that
thirty lemon what's up my man that's
what it is man and honestly and honestly
honestly that that to me is the best
part to your point I'm gonna put it out
because I don't want you having the
pressure of that that's just what's fun
that's the zeitgeist but that's real and
like you have an advantage in the way
you communicate to the point of like
some people write things and they're
trying to go backwards on saying some
funny [ __ ] to hope it pops put some
great beat on it let me make up a
[ __ ] word and see if he can go you're
writing about your life and when you
write about your life you've got a big
advantage for the model that I've been
sitting on in my head it's interesting
right
[Laughter]
especially not trying to be inspired and
figure out a way to keep doing something
to me I think the thing that you're
gonna get to is you're gonna want to get
to probably where I am creatively in
marketing and communications which is
after you get good at your craft after
you scratched a couple of those itches
you want to start inventing [ __ ] and
there's only there's only so many ways
you can invent within the box that you
already know you're trying to scratch
that itch I think that we haven't
thought about music dimensionally enough
to understand what the new distribution
channels have awarded us that's why when
I talk about what I just said it's a big
idea because it's staying within the
confines but it's creating new territory
that hasn't been there much like a remix
or like collaborations with a country
star or an influencer who like there's
just new little things that could never
be done before right like the music
video that was just like there wasn't
that in 1972 then there was then it
became the art then there wasn't like
like you know and to me that's what so
but when I know who somebody who's
writing real [ __ ] yeah that is super
interesting a project that took two
years to come out a song that resonates
a truth that there is a follow-up story
not fabricated that you can get
generated about and then it comes out 11
days later and everybody's been feeling
that song and now you're telling what
happened you're feeding them okay I bet
you didn't think that was coming today
oh yeah let's get this pictures too
right
I go vertical on this one hope you guys
enjoyed it hope you loved it
leave your 3 cents in the comments
subscribe tag homies share this with
everybody in hip-hop that loves hip-hop
because cretton I chopped it up for real
[Music]
you
[Music]